[Musik]
der strand der französischen küstenstadt
calais hier ist maria seinem traum ganz
nah
ich wäre der glücklichste mann der welt
wenn ich damit fahren könnte
der sudanese will nach england seit
anfang august haben das mehr als 1000
flüchtlinge von calais aus mit dem
schlauchboot geschafft noch nie waren es
so viele die briten rüsten auf
schließlich war die kontrolle der
grenzen eines der wichtigsten
versprechen des brh exit an die
bevölkerung die überfahrten gehen
trotzdem weiter
nun sollen flugzeuge der luftwaffe und
spezialkräfte der royal navy den
ärmelkanal und passierbar machen
für die bürgermeisterin von calais
gleicht das einer maritimen
kriegserklärung an die franzosen
doch nasir den flüchtlingen aus dem
sudan beeindruckt diese verschärfte
grenzsicherung überhaupt nicht die
britische regierung will keine neuen
menschen und zu land lassen aber das
land ist groß es kann viele menschen
aufnehmen wir werden das schon unseren
platz finden um seine flucht zu
organisieren hat er in calais aus die
stadt ist seit jahren ein transit ort
doch die infrastruktur für die bis zu
1500 geflüchteten ist schlecht aufnahmen
aus seinem alltag ein zeltlager am
straßenrand
kaum elektrizität kaum zugang zu wasser
und nahrungsmitteln
staatliche auffanglager nicht vorhanden
in dieser lagerhalle in calais arbeiten
britische und französische angeles
zusammen an einer grundversorgung für
die geflüchteten ich schäme mich auf in
den ministerin patel sagt dass die
flüchtlinge keinen grund haben
frankreich zu verlassen weil das doch
hier so ein sicheres land sei das zeugt
von so viel ignoranz der situation hier
gegenüber auch amt von er arbeitet seit
jahren in calais er sorgt sich denn die
lebensbedingungen werden immer
schlechter
der zugang zu wasser und nahrung ist
eher eingeschränkt im moment deshalb
sind diese hilfsorganisationen so
wichtig weil sie tag und nacht vorräte
verteilen da ist das holzlager das
bereiten wir für den winter form wir
brauchen starkes holz trockenes holz
damit kann man sich dann ein feuer
machen um sich aufzuwärmen zu kochen um
wasser zu erhitzen um sich zu waschen
[Musik]
warum die regierung alles daran setzt
keine feste infrastruktur für die
flüchtlinge zu ermöglichen erklärt er
sich so der staat hat angst dass ihr
eine zweite heimliche stadt entstehen
könnte sowie 2016 deshalb diese politik
der erschöpfung alles zu tun dass die
menschen hier nicht bleiben wollen
2016 war das anders
der junge so wurde das camp genannt 8000
flüchtlinge hausen damals auf
brachflächen rund um den fährhafen von
calais die meisten sind illegal hier
warten auf die große chance nach england
zu kommen
bei unserem besuch 2016 führt uns eine
helferin durchs camp
hier ist das offizielle container camp
der regierung vor allem sind die
schlafsäle und umgebaute container sie
sind einigermaßen sicher aber nicht
sonderlich freundlich da drüben gibt es
fast nur zelte darlegen viele sudanesen
ein großes problem sind die duschen die
wurden eigentlich nur für 300 menschen
eingerichtet
duschen toiletten sanitäre anlagen sind
ein riesenproblem
auch der sudanesische ab 2016 im
dschungel gelebt mit planen und
wellblech haben sie sich eine art heim
geschaffen unter den flüchtlingen im
camp herrscht das faustrecht erklärt er
deswegen leben sie hier zu dritt
zusammen das sei sicherer
welche rolle ich bin überrascht von
europa ich dachte das leben hier ist so
fortschrittlich aber es lebt sich sehr
primitiv man schläft auf der straße
nutzt holz um ein feuer zu machen und um
zu kochen
irgendwie grotesk zwei zelte weiterlebt
damals der 16 jährige afghane bashir
neun monate lang jede nacht versucht er
auf irgendeinen lkw zu klettern richtung
großbritannien er würde dort gerne die
schule besuchen
wir laufen weit raus auf die autobahn
eine stunde von hier wir versuchen die
fahrbahn zu blockieren
es gibt leute die bäume abschlagen und
die dann auf die straße schmeißen ich
mag diese methode nicht so dass es sehr
gefährlich
ich suche lieber nach parkplätzen wo ich
in lkws klettern kann
hinter der fahrerkabine ist ein schmaler
spalt da kann man gut drauf klettern und
sich von oben in die planen schneiden
bisher hat es aber nie geklappt aber ich
werde nicht aufgeben auch wenn ich dabei
draufgehen ich meine was soll denn hier
aus mir werden
immer wenn die sonne untergeht strömen
junge männer richtung autobahn solche
szenen spielen sich seit 2016 über
monaten nacht für nacht ab für die
polizisten bedeutet das großaufgebot
doch alle flüchtlinge konnten und können
sie nicht davon abhalten im lkw die
gefährliche reise anzutreten
dieser mann wäre dabei fast gestorben er
zeigt uns damals ein video wie er und 18
andere eingeschlossen in einem tanker um
ihr leben hämmern
[Musik]
schließlich wollen sie die polizei rufen
kein netz in belgien kann der tanker
gestoppt werden
die flüchtlinge werden befreit drei von
ihnen waren bereits ohnmächtig den
dschungel gibt es nicht mehr dafür
sorgen täglich dutzende polizisten alle
48 stunden razzia
zelte persönliche sachen bin regelmäßig
konfisziert die klare botschaft bleiben
unerwünschte rory dokumentiert die
räumungen jeden morgen notiert
menschenrechtsverletzungen will sichtbar
machen wie angespannt die situation ist
videoauswertung am mobilen arbeitsplatz
hier sieht man wie die polizei ankommt
und die menschen antreibt und so
auffällt sie stoßen die zelte wegdrücken
mit ihren schulen dagegen und sagen
ihnen dass sie verschwinden sollen
[Musik]
alles taktik politischer wille von einer
regierung die seit jahren keine lösung
findet um einen flüchtlings hotspot
lahmzulegen
es ist eine konstante schikane von der
polizei die menschen können sich nicht
ordentlich hinlegen
die meisten wurden die zelte weggenommen
während der großen räumungen ihm bleiben
nur isomatte und schlafsack sie wissen
nicht wo sie sich hinlegen sollen die
polizei in der nacht wieder kommt seit
dem ende des dschungels seit 2016 wurde
jede form von infrastruktur die kostet
abgeschafft der staat versucht alles
dass die flüchtlinge unsichtbar sind
hilfsorganisationen dürfen nicht in der
stadt verteilen sie sagen ihr könnt da
verteilen wurde niemand lebt das ist
hier generell so sie versuchen die
menschen dauernd aus calais heraus zu
treiben ohne irgendwelche hilfsangebote
zu schaffen alles damit sie unsichtbar
bleiben für die bevölkerung
man kann die geflüchteten verdrängen
sichtbar bleiben sie trotzdem am
kreisverkehr gibt es nun
toilettenhäuschen grünflächen und
parkplätze sind die neuen treffpunkte
der einzige ausweg mit dem schlauchboot
über den ärmelkanal
auch nasir will das unbedingt probieren
wir benutzen boote zum rüberkommen
solche kleinen boote die die europäer
zum planschen benutzen im meer einige
paddeln einige haben einen motor von
hier nach großbritannien sind es 34
kilometer es dauert drei stunden
wenn du paddeln muss das zehn bis elf
stunden es sind die frühen morgenstunden
an denen besonders viele boote ablegen
sollen überwachung kaum möglich 41
kilometern müssen wir überwachen das ist
viel wenn man die vielzahl an orten
betrachtet und diffamierungen der küste
mit den vielen klippen
das ist schwer die einheiten wurden
diesen sommer aufgestockt 45
polizeikräfte zusätzlich am tag
finanziert von den briten sogar die
reiter patrouille ist im einsatz
fast jeden morgen patroullieren wir in
den dünen und am strand oder hier an der
steilküste um die abfahrten zu
verhindern wir patroullieren auf dem
pferd wir so viel mehr und viel weiter
sehen
unsere pferde sind mindestens ein meter
10 hoch so schaffen wir es auch menschen
im dick zu sichten
die sich verstecken normalerweise finden
wir immer irgendwo boote oder kleidung
doch verhindern können sie nur einen
bruchteil der abwarten
in diesem sommer müssen seenotretter
fast täglich ausrücken
der ärmelkanal ist sehr gefährliche
strömungen man muss die risiken kennen
denen man sich aussetzt und man muss
wissen dass der ärmelkanal eine autobahn
ist und eine autobahn mit einem
tretroller zu befahren ist echt
gefährlich so kann man das hier
vergleichen
trotzdem wagen ist täglich hunderte wir
haben nichts zu verlieren sagt nase ich
werde es schaffen mitten in westeuropa
ist eine neue fluchtroute entstanden die
die politiker mit aller macht verdrängen
wollen
[Musik]